In this video, we'll
create a basic line plot
to visualize crime trends.
Let's start by
reading in our data.
We'll call it mvt for
motor vehicle thefts,
and use the read.csv function
to read in the file mvt.csv.
We'll add the argument
stringsAsFactors = FALSE,
since we have a
text field, and we
want to make sure
it's read in properly.
Let's take a look at the
structure of our data
using the str function.
We have over
190,000 observations
of three different variables--
the date of the crime,
and the location of
the crime, in terms
of latitude and longitude.
We want to first convert the
Date variable to a format
that R will recognize so that we
can extract the day of the week
and the hour of the day.
We can do this using
the strptime function.
So we want to replace
our variable, Date,
with the output of the
strptime function, which
takes as a first argument
our variable, Date, and then
as a second argument the
format that the date is in.
Here, we can see in the
output from the str function
that our format is the month
slash the day slash the year,
and then the hour colon minutes.
So our format equals, "%m/%d/%y
%H:%M", close the parentheses,
and hit Enter.
In this format, we can
extract the hour and the day
of the week from
the Date variable,
and we can add these as new
variables to our data frame.
We can do this by first
defining our new variable,
mvt$Weekday =
weekdays(mvt$Date).
Then, to add the hour,
which we'll call mvt$Hour,
we just take the hour
variable out of Date variable.
This only exists because we
converted the Date variable.
Let's take a look at the
structure of our data
again to see what it looks like.
Now, we have two more
variables-- Weekday,
which gives the day
of the week, and Hour,
which gives the hour of the day.
Now, we're ready to
make some line plots.
Let's start by
creating the line plot
we saw in the previous video
with just one line and a value
for every day of the week.
We want to plot as that
value the total number
of crimes on each
day of the week.
We can get this
information by creating
a table of the Weekday variable.
This gives the total amount of
crime on each day of the week.
Let's save this
table as a data frame
so that we can pass it
to ggplot as our data.
We'll call it WeekdayCounts, and
use the as.data.frame function
to convert our table
to a data frame.
Let's see what this looks
like with the str function.
We can see that our data frame
has seven observations, one
for each day of the week,
and two different variables.
The first variable,
called Var1, gives
the name of the day of the
week, and the second variable,
called Freq, for frequency,
gives the total amount of crime
on that day of the week.
Now, we're ready
to make our plot.
First, we need to load
the ggplot2 package.
So we'll type library(ggplot2).
Now, we'll create our plot
using the ggplot function.
So type ggplot, and
then we need to give
the name of our data,
which is WeekdayCounts.
And then we need to
define our aesthetic.
So our aesthetic
should have x = Var1,
since we want the day of
the week on the x-axis,
and y = Freq, since
we want the frequency,
the number of crimes,
on the y-axis.
Now, we just need to add
geom_line(aes(group=1)).
This just groups all of
our data into one line,
since we want one
line in our plot.
Go ahead and hit Enter.
We can see that this is very
close to the plot we want.
We have the total
number of crime plotted
by day of the week, but
our days of the week
are a little bit out of order.
We have Friday first, then
Monday, then Saturday,
then Sunday, etc.
What ggplot did was it
put the days of the week
in alphabetical order.
But we actually want the days of
the week in chronological order
to make this plot a
bit easier to read.
We can do this by making the
Var1 variable an ordered factor
variable.
This signals to ggplot that
the ordering is meaningful.
We can do this by using
the factor function.
So let's start by typing
WeekdayCounts$Var1,
the variable we want to
convert, and set that equal
to the output of
the factor function,
where the first argument is our
variable, WeekdayCounts$Var1,
the second argument
is ordered = TRUE.
This says that we want
an ordered factor.
And the third argument,
which is levels,
should be equal to
a vector of the days
of the week in the order
we want them to be in.
We'll use the c
function to do this.
So first, in quotes,
type "Sunday" --
we want Sunday first-- and
then "Monday", "Tuesday",
"Wednesday", "Thursday",
"Friday", "Saturday".
Go ahead and close both
parentheses and hit Enter.
Now, let's try our plot again by
just hitting the up arrow twice
and hitting Enter.
Now, this is the plot we want.
We have the total crime
by day of the week
with the days of the week
in chronological order.
The last thing we'll
want to do to our plot
is just change the
x- and y-axis labels,
since they're not very
helpful as they are now.
To do this, back
in the R console,
just hit the up arrow to get
back to our plotting line,
and then we'll add
xlab("Day of the Week").
And then we'll add ylab("Total
Motor Vehicle Thefts").
Now, this is the
plot we were trying
to generate with descriptive
labels on the x- and y-axis.
In the next video, we'll
add the hour of the day
to our line plot, and
then create a heat map.